You can't pause a movie on the big screen,
but don't you wish you could sometimes? To
get a better look at Batman's first big
moment? Or to see all the details in
the Riddler's hideout? Keep watching for
more pause-worthy "The Batman" moments.
The opening sequence to "The Batman" will easily
be one of the most talked about scenes, just
because of the foreboding tone it sets. It's akin
to the swelling dread one feels as Michael Myers
stalks his prey in a "Halloween" movie. The victim
here is Gotham's mayor, who sits unsuspecting in
the privacy of his luxurious abode. As the mayor
views the public reaction to his own campaign
being broadcast on television, he's entirely
unaware of the danger that lurks in the shadows.
Hauntingly, the figure of the Riddler is seen
lying in wait not even five feet away from his
intended victim. Paul Dano's acting skill is
on full display here — he can make your skin
crawl with just the movement of his eyes.
There's a lot to savor in this sequence,
particularly for viewers who have an appreciation
for horror themes and a creepy atmosphere.
The arrival of a film's title character
is often cause for a grand entrance,
especially for a character as popular as
Batman. After the film moves on from its
horrifying introduction of the Riddler, Robert
Pattinson's Bruce Wayne speaks to the audience via
a sullen voiceover that underscores the
bleak and depressing outlook of a city
riddled with crime. While he's unsure whether he's
actually doing any good, there's one thing he is
certain of: Criminals feel uneasy when the Bat
Signal shines in the sky, and for good reason.
"When that light hits the sky, it's
not just a call. It's a warning."
On a subway, a gang that looks to be inspired
by the Joker, based on their face paint,
targets an unlucky soul and begins assaulting the
poor man. Quickly, the sounds of footsteps can be
heard from within the dark tunnel opposite
the attackers. The gang stops and looks on,
waiting to see what emerges from the dark. As
Batman steps out into the light, he provides
a demonstration of his fear-inducing tactics by
brutalizing the gang's apparent leader in front of
them. Some stay and fight, while others flee. It's
a visceral display of Batman's rage, and the scene
earns its place as a crowd-pleasing
starting point for Batman's journey.
Long before "The Batman" arrived in theaters,
audiences knew for quite some time that the
Penguin was going to have a role in the film.
Given that the story takes place early in Batman's
crime fighting career, the Penguin isn't quite
yet the crime lord comics readers know him to be.
He operates the Iceberg Lounge under the
mob-backed supervision of Carmine Falcone.
Colin Farrell absolutely disappears into the
Penguin beneath prosthetics and make-up work.
Despite his altered appearance, he manages
to nail the mannerisms of an egomaniacal
crook vying for power. All the fun begins
when the Dark Knight heads to the Iceberg
and questions the Penguin regarding his possible
associations with the recently deceased mayor.
Seeing the Penguin and knowing that Colin Farrell
is buried beneath that grungy exterior and slimy
attitude is quite impressive. Viewers might
find themselves scanning the character for any
identifiable aspect of the Farrell they remember,
but they'll be hard-pressed to find anything.
Despite his own penchant for crime and corruption,
the Penguin positions himself as one of
the film's more interesting characters,
even though he has little to do with
the burgeoning threat of the Riddler.
Throughout the film, the Riddler taunts the
residents of Gotham with each kill. Of course,
he believes that he's doing the city a service
by rooting out corruption. He also wants to get
Batman's attention, hoping that the vigilante will
side with him in his crusade to punish the wicked.
"I think I'm his last target."
The news regularly shows recorded
threats that the Riddler has posted
in an effort to gain clout and
attention throughout his campaign.
When the police finally detain the
Riddler, they investigate his apartment,
which is littered with newspaper clippings
and details of Gotham's past and present.
The Riddler's cluttered abode contains secrets
and details that many fans will certainly want
to pause and scour for clues to a larger world
beyond Gotham City. When the Riddler discusses
the affluent Wayne and Arkham families, eagle-eyed
fans can see a clipping referencing Edward Elliot,
another famous Gotham City aristocrat.
Those who remember the Elliot family from
the "Batman" comics will recognize
this as a nod to Tommy Elliot,
Bruce's former childhood friend, who
grows up to become the villainous Hush.
A Batman movie just wouldn't be
an epic Dark Knight tale without
a thrilling Batmobile sequence.
"The Batman" doesn't disappoint.
Batman unveils his monster machine with a
thunderous rumble. As the Dark Knight pursues
the Penguin in an effort to learn whether he's an
informant in a case the Riddler keeps referencing,
he has to deal with the dangerous criminal's
collateral damage. The Penguin enters
the freeway driving the wrong direction,
dodging cars and causing massive pile-ups.
At one point, the Penguin causes a collision
that includes a truck carrying liquid fuel.
Looking in his rear view mirror, he believes
the Batman was either forced to stop his pursuit
or taken out in the explosion of the
truck's trailer. He hollers for joy…
"I got you! Ha ha ha! I got you!"
…but his excitement is short-lived,
as the Batmobile comes careening out
of the flames much to the Penguin's
horror. Hot-rod enthusiasts who love
cars with some serious muscle and fans
of the Batmobile will definitely want to
admire the stunt work and thrilling visuals
on display during this harrowing sequence.
The relationship between Batman and Catwoman has
long been one of the most entertainingly complex
in comics. Although it has yet to be fully
explored on the big screen, audiences have
had several opportunities to see the Bat and the
Cat in action. Michelle Pfeiffer's [FY-fur] take
on the role in 1992's "Batman Returns," is
unforgettable, and Anne Hathaway put her
own spin on the character when Selina Kyle fought
side by side with the Caped Crusader in "The Dark
Knight Rises." "The Batman," however, gives us
what might be the most comics-accurate portrayal
of Catwoman yet, with Zoë [ZOH-ee] Kravitz
donning the leather bodysuit and cat-burglar mask.
When Batman follows Selina to find out
how she's involved in the case at hand,
he discovers her breaking into a safe, commenting
on her uncanny ability to crack them so easily.
Startled, she turns around and starts
fighting him. The sequence fits neatly
into the narrative while doubling as thrilling
fan service for everyone in the audience who's
been looking forward to seeing these
characters come together onscreen again.
If viewers look closely, they can even see that
Selina is sporting some wickedly long fingernails,
prime for catlike scratch attacks.
Thankfully, the clash is brief.
Just as they have so many times before,
Batman and Catwoman quickly form an alliance.
As many viewers will no doubt suspect,
the Riddler's capture isn't the end,
but it does set up his endgame. Despite his
arrest, he has power in the form of a group
of radical followers he's amassed. They detonate
bombs he's planted on Gotham's reservoir walls,
causing a devastating amount of water to pour
into the city. When Batman finally comes to
realize the Riddler's terrible plot, fiery
explosions can be seen erupting throughout
the city in a scene reminiscent of Bane's
assault on Gotham in "The Dark Knight Rises."
The results are horrifying, as residents
of Gotham clamor to reach higher ground and
water sweeps through the streets. The
moment adds some serious tension when
audiences sit back and realize
that the Riddler may have won.
It's not often that the bad guy walks away as
the victor, but this villain managed to bring
widespread destruction to Gotham. The film's
resolution settles on Batman understanding that
he has to do whatever he can to help Gotham's
innocents in the face of unrepentant evil.
With the Riddler locked up tight at Arkham,
he can no longer do any harm directly.
But he's covered himself by rallying
extremists to his cause through his
online presence. With Gotham City flooding
and descending into mass panic and chaos,
the group seeks to assassinate a mayoral candidate
and kill as many as they can at a political rally.
The group positions themselves high up on a rafter
where they rain down a hail of bullets upon the
innocents below. Batman, once again, makes a
grand entrance by demolishing the top of the
building with explosives and dropping onto the
rafter before engaging the Riddler's disciples.
The Dark Knight pummels and defeats bad guy
after bad guy in a thrilling combat sequence.
Still early in his career, Batman isn't
quite the near-perfect crimefighter we
know he'll one day become after accruing years
of experience on the job. He's attacked from
a blind spot and nearly falls off the
rafters. Surveying his surroundings,
he employs the use of smoke to distract his
enemies while he takes each down one by one.
"The Batman" establishes Batman
and Catwoman's relationship
well. Both have aided each other
and even saved each other's lives.
Their paths are interconnected, and Selina
senses that when she kisses the Dark Knight.
She pleads with him to skip town with her before
realizing he's too fixated on helping build a
better Gotham City. While she doesn't believe
the city will ever change, Batman has hope.
As the two set off on their own paths, they
speed away on their respective motorcycles.
Despite this scene coming at the tail
end of the film, it's the first moment
viewers can admire the Batcycle in all of its
simplicity and beauty. While bleak themes of
corruption and darkness pervade "The Batman,"
seeing the Caped Crusader and Catwoman racing
down the road together side by side offers a
glimmer of hope and optimism for the future.
Even though they ultimately go their
separate ways, it's hard to believe
Selina Kyle is out of Batman's life for good
after all they've been through together.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.